Here's what I did before making this video. I was at home watching K-pop videos.
When suddenly I felt useless and pathetic because I just spent two hours
watching four girls say
I needed some sort of confirmation that I was still wanted and loved in this
world. So I called my mom.
She didn't pick up. She never does.
So I needed a new way to feel validated my next best thing.
My data science skills I needed to feel wanted.
So I revamped my resume and brushed my hair and applied to all these data
science analytics positions. I whispered to myself, tell me you want me?
I quickly learned that it takes more than 20 minutes to get an interview. So I,
um, brushed my hair, took my pants off and went to bed soon.
The interview started flowing in one phone call, two phone call,
three phone call rejection. You win some, you lose some.
I started getting on-site interviews one onsite, two onsite,
three onsite at every interview I whispered to them, tell me you want me,
some did some didn't, but I had what I need I'm validated.
And here is what I learned from all these things.
[Inaudible].
So for the technical interview,
this is basically just a simple SQL or SQL question,
or it can also be a simple coding question like Python or something.
And the reason why they ask you this question is to make sure that you know how
to write queries, because they're going to be doing a lot of that on a job.
And also if you can work with a simple program,
if you could write simple programs, nothing too complicated. Now,
not going to lie at this part of the interview or this interview is probably
going to be the easiest out of the data science analytics position.
So let's see if you can solve one of these questions. Here's an example.
So here you have a table called publisher info that has all the information
about a publisher and the videos they publish.
And then you have the consumption info where you have all the information of
user consuming, a single video. So two questions, one,
how many minutes worth of video does an average publisher have to,
how many publishers have at least one user who watched their videos?
I'll give you 10 seconds to finish.
So here's the answer.
In a real interview. There will be more up questions since it's an hour long,
but let me show you how I studied for it.
I locked myself in a room and open cracking the coding interview and finish all
the questions until chapter five or until I feel like puking. After that,
I go to all these websites to practice SQL questions.
And of course I go on glassdoor.com to see if we could find any juicy
questions, the math interview,
or sometimes they call it the quantitative interview.
This one is quite simple also because they just asked you some simple
probability questions or some simple descriptive statistics.
So here's an example.
It takes an STD test and the test is advertised as being nine, 9% accurate.
If you have the STD, your test positive nine, 9% of the time.
If you don't have the STD, you will test negative nine, 9% of the time.
If 1% of all people have this SDB and Jorma test positive,
what is the probability that Joma has this disease?
I'll give you a few seconds to answer this question.
Tick-tock tick-tock tick-tock tick-tock tick-tock tick-tock tick-tock
so the answer is zero because you have to get late togetherness.
Okay. Anyways, the right answer is 50% and you have to use beta.
So if you went to college and you listen during your freshman year,
these concepts should be pretty familiar to you, but then again,
that's only if you remember them.
So here's a list of things that they would ask you about.
So like conditional probabilities based theorem by normal distribution,
normal distribution, descriptive statistics,
and like understanding the law of large numbers,
central limit theorem and linear regressions.
So if you understand these concepts, that's pretty good and you should be fine.
And then for me, I wasn't fine because I didn't listen.
So what I did to study for that, I went back to my old textbooks,
read some of these chapters and then refresh my memory.
And then also I did some practice questions, especially for probabilities,
because sometimes it's a little bit tricky. It's almost like a brain teaser.
So you just got to practice just like coding the product interview.
Now this is a little bit subjective, but it's important to get, right?
They will ask you a hypothetical product and how you improve it.
And then they will also ask you what metrics would you track to measure its
success. Also,
they're going to give you situations where there are trade-offs between metrics
and you have to argue which one is best for the product.
It's not always black and white.
We just want to know how well did you work with data in the products
perspective? So it's kind of hard to give you an example of a question.
Cause usually it's like a back and forth and a conversation.
So here's an example of what the interview would look like. All right.
So as you know,
not vine is a platform where users can share 6.1 looping videos
as seen in the startup series. And it's basically a feed of content. You follow.
Now,
imagine we are considering launching a share button where you can share someone
else's video and it will show to your followers,
how would you evaluate this change?
What metrics do you expect to change and how will you decide to launch it or
not? Hmm, well,
we can do an experiment rollout to only a few publishers first and then AB
tested. So for some users, they see it. And for some,
they don't see the shared post.
That way we can see the difference in consumer behavior. For example,
inventory will probably go up because of that.
We will see if it increases video, watch time per person.
And if it increases retention from users with this feature,
we also have to make sure it doesn't cannibalize the original content.
So even if they have more video impressions,
we want to see if the view impressions didn't decrease too much,
which can mean they don't care about the shared videos.
We can also run surveys to survey them if they enjoy watching this shared
content. So, so product questions are like that,
but usually with more follow-ups and more deep dives, but you get the gist.
So obviously this is a generalizations of all the data science interviews.
I've had. Some are harder, some are easier,
but if you were able to answer these question,
your chance of getting a data science job is higher with
statistical significance than if you weren't able to answer these questions.
By the way, this video was sponsored by brilliant.org,
which is kind of cool because I actually used trillian.org.
When I was applying to my untitled large company,
since the company gave me links to help me prepare for my interview.
And one of the links that they gave me is a bunch of competent torics questions,
AKA probably questions on brilliant.org.
It really helped me on the map part of the interview because I was killing the
probability questions.
I actually find it really fun to crank out these questions.
It makes me feel good about myself and keeps me sharp.
And they're good brain teasers for interviews,
especially for data science or quantum.
Very good supplement to my interview preps. So highly recommended. Also,
if you're in school,
you could supplement your learning by using this website because there's a wide
variety of topics,
which is pretty dope because I love the UI on the website and it makes studying
so much more fun with their quizzes. If you're interested,
there's a link in the description down below, best of all,
you can get 20% off their premium subscription. So YouTube,
you can kill it at the interview for the large entitled company. All right.
Hope you enjoyed this video or I gotta go now pose, um,
after figuring out how to make food. Cause my roommates are gone.
I've been eating Cheetos for like the past two days.
Yeah.
[inaudible].